hi there in this sample I will
demonstrate how to use the apigee maven
deploy plugin to deploy a sharp flow
from your source code to apigee using
Cloud build
apigee Maven plugin is a tool for
building and deploying the bundles into
your apigee platform
and Cloud build is a fully managed
continuous integration delivery and
deployment platform that lets you run
fast consistent and reliable automated
bills
the prerequisites for this sample are
have an apigee X provisioned and
configure external access for API
traffic as a user you will need access
to deploy shared flows to your apigee
environment and also trigger Cloud build
job in your gcp project also you will
need tools like gcloud unzip curl and JQ
installed
now this sample can be demonstrated
using the quick start available through
Cloud shell or following the setup
instructions in this video we will be
using the cloud shell QuickStart
click the open in Google Cloud shell to
open the cloud shell environment once
the environment is loaded let's follow
the instructions provided in the
tutorial
now that we have our Cloud shell
tutorial completely loaded let's go
through a tutorial that we have on the
very right now the first thing we will
have to do is to set up the environment
now for that let's first go through the
login process
foreign
love
copy my auth code
paste it over here
and that's logged in now let's go into
the appropriate directory in our case
it's deploy apigee shared flow
now let's click the click here link that
takes us to the file editor now in this
file editor we basically have different
variables that we need to populate
we have the project ID we have the
apigee environment so let's go ahead and
fill that out
now let's save the file
and then let's Source the env.sh file
let's click authorize
then let's click Start
now the next step what we'll have to do
is we basically will enable the cloud
build API so let's click this command
that basically enables the cloud build
on this gcp project
now once it's enabled let's make sure
that the cloud build service account has
the apigee arc admin role to do the
deployments for us
now that's complete let's trigger off
the cloud build job using the ccloud
command and passing the apigee
environment that we had sourced to the
env.sh file
now this is going to take a few minutes
once the cloud build job is complete you
should see a status that says success
and at the end of the cloud build
trigger you will actually see a shared
flow that is deployed to the fpg
environment with the name sample hello
cicbsf now let's login to the apigee
console and just go to develop and click
chat flows
you'll see that there is a sample hello
cicd SF deployed a minute ago
now let's go back in here now that
verifies that we were able to deploy the
shared flow and once you're done with
this you can actually go up and clean up
your artifacts for that you just have to
run the cleanup script that we have
once that's complete you can go back and
you can make sure that it's deleted from
your apigee environment thanks for
watching I hope this content was useful
to you if you have not signed up for
apigee yet use this link and if you have
any questions please visit the apigee
community